Now that we've described the
position vector of the runner,
let's try to describe
what happens in time
as a runner moves
along our road.
Suppose at a later time our
runner has gone down the road
just a little bit.
And so the runner has
moved a little bit.
Remember, at time t, we
described the position vector
r(t) was equal to the
coordinate function
x as a function of time i hat.
And this distance
here was our x(t).
Now, our position vector
a little bit later.
So here we are at
time t plus delta t.
The runner has
moved a little bit.
And we'll now describe
the position vector--
because I don't
want to overlap it--
that center point is up here.
It's going to point
in this direction.
And this is what we
call r(t) plus delta t.
In that vector,
r(t) plus delta t,
the coordinate function
is no longer at time t
but t plus delta t i hat.
And we would now
like to describe
the displacement vector.
So our next step is to describe
the displacement vector
for the interval t
to t plus delta t.
And that displacement vector
is defined-- we use the symbol
delta r, and what we
mean is the vector r(t)
plus delta t minus
the vector r(t).
Now, what that
vector corresponds to
is the vector right here.
This is our delta r.
And if we now use our
two definitions here,
then this becomes x(t) plus
delta t minus x(t) i hat.
And this quantity here we
refer to as the component
of the displacement vector.
So delta x is the component
And as before, the
component can be positive,
which would correspond
to the person moving
a positive component,
positive i hat direction,
in the positive x direction
as shown in this figure.
If the displacement
of vector is zero,
the person could
have run forward
and come back and at
time t plus delta t
be in exactly the
same spot as time t.
The displacement vector
is zero in that case.
The displacement
vector could have
a component that's negative.
And what negative means is at
the end of this interval-- t
plus delta t-- that the person
is to the left of the runner.
And so this quantity
would be negative.
And so this is our crucial
displacement vector that
describes only the difference
in positions between the person,
between time t plus
delta t, and time t.